the NBA is now finding teams over 1
million dollars for resting their star
players well it's a little more
complicated than that they are setting
in a rule that no more than one star
player can be unavailable for a game
another rule is if a star player is
wrestling for a game they must be
present and visible to fans so if the
Phoenix Suns are playing Kevin Durant
and Devin Booker can't both be rested
but hold on hold on what even
constitutes a star player according to
Shams a star is defined as someone who
has made All-Star or all NBA team in the
past three seasons so Klay Thompson not
a star Paolo benjero not a star the NBA
clearly feels like wrestling has gotten
out of control I mean imagine if you
finally save up money to go see your
favorite team and see your favorite
player only to get there and your
favorite player decides to rest for the
night the first time a team breaks this
rule they are fined a hundred thousand
dollars then they're fined 250 000 on
their second offense and then they're
hit with 1.25 million dollars on their
third offense the NBA is not playing
around